Jem's in washington we have all our
monthly bills paid with our Visa card
everything we buy is also paid with Visa
we pay off the visa bill on time and
have never paid interest on our visa we
use our airline miles at least every two
years we have no debt and enjoy
traveling with free miles what do you
say why do you say this is wrong because
Jim it's very simple personal finances
80% behavior it's only 20% head
knowledge and several different studies
have confirmed that when you pay for
things with plastic you spend more than
when you pay with cash just in your mind
right now lay out hundred-dollar bills
on the table in front of you and your
mind lay out five Benjamin Franklin's in
front of you on the table and in your
mind lay a piece of plastic down there
that says visa on it one of those is
activating the emotional center sensors
in your brain and the other one is not
when you lay Benjamin Franklin down at
the grocery store or to buy a piece of
clothing or a pair of shoes and he
doesn't come back your brain says ouch
when you lay a piece of plastic down
here's what's interesting and Rachel
pointed this out to me a few years ago I
hadn't caught this part of it you know
when we're kids we learned to trade
things you know back in the day you know
in the 1930s or 40s you might have
traded marbles your grandparents monitor
ated a blue marble for a green marble
right and some of you might have traded
a toy for a different toy and that kind
of things you learn too if you give
something you receive something there's
a there's a transaction has occurred and
so when you give the money you receive
the item I give them a two hundred to
one hundred dollar bills and maybe I get
a little change and I get a pair of
shoes and I walk away right maybe I get
some change and depending on you and
where you're buying shoes and so forth
right but anyway you see what I'm
talking about you hand money over you
leave with shoes
here's what happens visually with a
credit
you hand a piece of plastic over they
hand it back to you and you leave with
that and the shoes and somehow that
tells your brain that you just got a
good deal that's weird isn't it but you
know we don't even think about stuff
like that but the studies show that you
spend 12 to 18 percent more when using
plastic over using plaster using cash
and actually Carnegie Mellon published a
study done by MIT where they used an MRI
function to study this and they hooked
up MRIs and to study the brain activity
and here's what happened when people
bought stuff with cash it activated the
pain centers in the brain and when you
bought stuff with plastic there was no
brain activity no brain that was my part
I added that ok but seriously I mean
again you're activating the pain centers
when you lay uncle Benjamin Franklin
down on one of those little black trays
in the restaurant we call them Uncle
Ben's coffin because you know when you
put him in there he ain't coming back
right and you can't what do you get back
you get back a little piece of white
paper this is ouch
and if you know you're doing that
McDonald's did this McDonald's several
years ago when I first started doing
this show fast food didn't take plastic
that's how long I've been doing the show
25 years right
fast food didn't take plastic and it was
a big deal it was kind of controversial
when McDonald's decided to take plastic
but they came out and said oh no no no
we've done studies and it's it helps us
with shrinkage meaning our employees
were stealing and if they're taking
plastic we don't have any think egde and
you know the consumer its convenience
for the consumer and I know not all of
that was a lie the actual studies were
done by McDonald's they were fabulous
they're fabulous marketers and they did
all these focus group studies they found
that when you walk into McDonald's with
a piece of plastic you're saying you
know supersize my meal so in the apple
pie and I'll pay for his the guy
standing behind you right when you walk
in McDonald's with cash you're like
dollar menu guy behind me you're on your
own
right and so you spend 78 percent more
on average in a fast food setting with
plastic than you do with cash that's why
McDonald start taking plastic does it
increase their particular impulse your
butt off is what it amounts to and so
and Jim you think you've got this
figured out by running everything
through visa because I'm sure you're
smarter than Chase I'm sure you're
smarter than Wells Fargo I'm sure they
haven't done any studies that have
figured out exactly where you're you
know where they're making money on you
in spite of this but you've got it
figured out you're taking on this
multi-billion dollar corporation that
are some of the most sophisticated
marketers on the planet and you're
kicking their butt come on do that's
arrogance beyond belief and you know you
so but I got a feeling that all of this
is wasted on you but I did it for
everybody else because you're going to
keep doing it because you're brilliant
there's that arrogance that goes with
this and so that that's what's happening
you can just count on it but the truth
is is that you are spending more on
average well no this is stuff I'd be
buying anyway bull bull hey listen go to
Disney and you stay on property your
room key becomes a debit card that goes
to your bill and you can use it anywhere
in the Disney parks and you're buying $8
ice cream cones ice cream cones and you
didn't think about it and Disney makes
it rain every afternoon because their
God there and they sell those little
little cheap plastic ponchos that they
got a buck and a half in and there's
some of them for $15 and you put them on
your room card you don't think anything
about it because you don't want your
hair to get wet this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
now